hey guys long time no see I hope you
guys haven't missed me too much first
off you're from Kansas I am I'm from the
good ol Midwest being from Kansas are
you one of those Johnson County snobs
how do you know that's not even yes I'm
from Jessica oh my goodness well that's
that okay well that's good hey guys this
is Jen and I'm so excited to share with
you this cute Korean style makeup
tutorial as you guys know I went to
Korea recently and I really enjoyed
seeing the differences in makeup and how
they apply them over there you didn't
major in makeup or anything like that
okay so my degree is in design
I studied industrial design and worked
as a signer for about three or four
years before I did the blogging and
youtubing thing as my job so yeah so
that's kind of my introduction to makeup
as just really loving our InDesign and I
just really like to be inspired and I
like making people feel really happy and
encouraged and beautiful and that's kind
of how I feel about what I do on YouTube
is you know I get to do tutorials that
make people feel more confident I get to
talk about things that were insecurities
in my life and the past that
you know I now overcome and just
encouraging other people to just really
love themselves I just wanted to give
you guys a little background on my skin
I get a lot of comments about my skin
people saying that it's nice and
honestly I struggled with acne for about
ten years
ever since I was about eleven until I
was 21
you kind of met the love of your life
then during backing back in the acne biz
yeah honestly I feel like that wasn't
even an issue like we were just both
really young and awkward and just you
know dating in high school and we ended
up just being really best friends and I
don't think that either of us were
really too concerned with necessarily
how we look I mean it was more about who
we were as people and how we connected
and that's always been the base priority
for me in any relationship not just you
know in marriage but also in friends
it's just important that you connect as
people hold it because it's like the
outside stuff like that's that's always
going to go away we're all going to age
and you know get wrinkly and some of us
will have acne and some of us will have
but I don't think that that should
define who we are as people because
ultimately who you are is how you choose
to define yourself and how you choose to
present yourself so
and if you've decided that who you are
is who you are inside and you show that
to the world then that can change other
people's perception of like what's
important in life I've seen a lot of
women with no makeup on and I have yet
to meet anybody that I didn't think was
beautiful so feel confident it's okay if
you have acne you're not gonna have it
forever it's something that can be
healed go see a doctor and stick with it
for at least four months and see what
happens
you know there's hope out there how much
promotion or publicity that you have to
do to kind of grow your channel um I
literally did none McGrew extremely
organically I've always just tried to
work hard making good content and I you
know like I said I'm from Kansas I
didn't have any network connections I
didn't have any know-how I am really
somebody who just kind of like learned
as I went along
one of my things in life that I like to
say is like hit the ground running even
if you don't know how to do something if
you're at least getting there you'll
figure it out
if you have given yourself to just run
in the first place and trip when you
trip and fall where you fall and get up
again so that's just yeah I'm not cool
like you cool how many people who all
know each other and doing lots of videos
together I just kind of did my own thing
I know I didn't lose my back he's stolen
he obviously didn't steal it if I'm
calling you right now so you're in LA
where are you New York now do you do a
lot of collaborations now or are you
still kind of mostly about yourself um
I've been really blessed to have made
some really amazing friends out here I
mean one of the first projects I even
came out to LA for in the first place
was doing a six-episode web series with
one through productions and that was
just acting
I was actually the lead actress in this
sort of like romantic comedy ish web
series and that was a lot of fun and
that was kind of my first taste at doing
something like a collaboration and I
think that that's so amazing that just
because it's fun to do but it's also
like amazing exposure I couldn't have
asked for cooler people to work with her
or they actually reached out to me I
mean like I said I'm not that cool I
don't know how to reach out to really
cool people I got but I think that those
those things are invaluable
collaborations are where it's at if you
want to really get deep roots in YouTube
hey everyone this is Jen from from head
to toe and this is a really simple
tutorial using just eyeliner and mascara
or a quick on the go look
now how did you get into YouTube then
was it makeup first then YouTube or
YouTube the makeup I just started
blogging I been blogging for about five
and a half years and like I said it just
started with buying things from the
drugstore and reviewing it just because
I thought maybe other people might want
to hear what real people think about it
before they went and bought something so
I was doing that for not quite a year
and I saw a couple of tutorials on
YouTube there weren't very many gurus
actually gurus didn't exist
I knew maybe like three girls who did
makeup on YouTube and I was like well I
have this blogging platform where I take
pictures and I have to like write out
descriptions and take pictures of every
single step while I'm doing it tutorial
wouldn't be so much easier if I could
just show people and so that's kind of
how mine started and so that kind of
capitulated into several videos and
spending way more time recording and
editing because I did not know that
YouTube took so much more time so much
time to record and edit and put
everything together and upgrade quality
constantly and just really be on top of
it and have like a consistent schedule
with it so it was kind of I fell into
this monster and I didn't know what I
was getting myself into but I think it
worked out was - managed Blankman
I really like it Tendo I'm hoping to
find a damn central area and I really
want to play a new person Bob you know
your kind of indie gaming and stuff I
mean so is there any plans they add like
a gaming channel I don't know if I would
go into a gaming channel because I know
the gaming world on YouTube is very
passionate and very intense and I would
say I love to gain but I'm almost
hesitant to even call myself a gamer
because I know a lot of girls who really
get called out like oh how can you call
yourself a gamer I'm a gamer but so I'm
a little scared about video but I do
love games I my MMO of choices Guild
Wars
I love SimCity I really love tons of
iPhone games like I get probably more
into my iPhone games than even my
husband does I don't think a lot of
shooter games but I don't really have
any qualms with making a fool of myself
playing them in front of people so you
know if collaborations come up in the
future I've thought about that and I've
also thought about integrating some of
that into my second channel which is
just sort of like a catch-all channel
like vlogs and travel videos and non
Beauty favorites and hopefully also some
games done okay well thank you very much
for sitting down with the media
rockstars and we're excited to see what
you've got next and I'm gonna do your
face and what you're gonna do to my face
alright so we're going to start off
using a skin primer this is a foundation
primer so that's going to help your
foundation to last all day and help keep
the oil ease under control a little bit
it's not on your order but if you wear
foundation every day like you do mm-hmm
it definitely helps it to last no I'm
not now as something is foundation
something that that guy's hand whereas a
like they just wouldn't I need to
explain you know I I have no background
in makeup whatsoever so I think that
it's very difficult to get a foundation
that's going to look if you do work in
media and you need some stuff on your
face for guys I would generally
recommend using a powder foundation
because that's going to help control the
oils and that's what really reflects a
lot in a lot of photography and film I
love makeup it's gonna be pretty awkward
if I if I really end up liking the new
me and I started a makeup all the time
should we move on to your eyes now
I think so thank you say eyes are the
windows to your soul and I'm such lovely
eyes really lovely eyes thank you yeah
okay so now I'm going to take an
eyeshadow primer another one okay you
happen to well thank you see this is
something I'm doing makeup on guys
something I've learned when you tell
girls to look up when you're putting on
their makeup they know how to look up
with their eyes when you're putting
makeup on guys they always told her
we're gonna call out the green in his
eyes we're gonna do maybe a lime green
and contour with some purple that sounds
very nice very Riddler yeah I can go
over there so how are you feeling
I feel pretty it's so so pretty it's so
pretty in well how did I come out well I
think that the final result is just
beautiful I haven't seen it yet but I
feel like it's kind of a Caribbean
sunset that is that a fair assessment
oh yeah oh we can't forget you no no my
untamed mane so here's here's our this
is like one of those reality shows and
unblemished representation
okay I think I'm gonna cry no oh I look
like a horse like the worst kind of oh
yeah you did a fantastic job you did
some marvelous blending my foundation
looks great
yeah that's hot that's popping you did
very good work